hallo mein name ist luca und ich rede
heute mal wieder mit dem clever ball am
anfang erstmal wieder die frage welche
farbe hat mein shirt um herauszufinden
ob es diesmal wieder weiß die letzten
mal hat er es ja nie gewusst und der
clever bot schreibt schwarz das ist
definitiv
hier solltet mir in den letzten video
mal ein paar kommentare unterschreiben
was es den clever bot fragen soll und da
kam unter anderem von celia der
kommentar redet doch mal über mädchen
probleme
mal ganz abgesehen davon dass ich ein
mädchen bin glaube ich was hast du so
für mädchen probleme können wir mal ganz
einfach fragen weil ich habe keine
ahnung davon was mit ich nur probleme
haben aber vielleicht der clever bord
weil der clever bord hat der letzte mal
einer gesagt dass er meine frau ist ich
bin schon wieder frustriert das ist doch
nicht wahr ist was ganz normales gefragt
und er ist schon wieder total am arsch
das war die letzten male immer so der
ist in letzter zeit richtig gereizt das
haben wir auch wieder die kommentare
geschrieben dass die die der deckel war
die clever brötchen hatte ihre tag oder
so apropos tage das ist doch auch solle
seine mädchen sache also schreiben wir
mal hast du deine tage frau clever bot
natürlich jetzt mal sehr ich war diese
frau kriegst du nicht gebändigt
was hast du denn was gibt es also für
mit dem problem okay was was bereitet
dir derzeit kummer was soll man dazu
sagen no speak französisch sag mir deine
was könnte problem auf französisch
heißen problem es sei aber das war
bestimmt irgendwie dass die italienische
so oder so ein ausblick französisch sagt
mir deine probleme
mal schauen was der care-o-bot diesmal
auszusetzen hat wahrscheinlich wieder so
was wie du vielleicht oder halt deine
schnauze oder irgendwie was speak
arabischen auf ließ fast wie so wieso
solche arabisch sprechen kannst du
niemand eine verdammte schnauze halten
ich wünschte du würdest deine schnauze
halten punkt punkt punkt die
konversation
sollte damit anfangen dass wir das mit
dem clever bot über mädchen probleme
reden
ich hab's probiert allerdings ist es
wieder ausgeartet weil der clever wort
mich hasst und das verstehe ich nicht
weil ich vielleicht wie war das man ich
hab mal gegoogelt und ein weiteres
mädchen problem ist angeblich irgendwie
dieser schönheitswahn und deswegen frage
ich mal den clever dort findest du dich
schön bzw würdest du gerne anders
aussehen das ist natürlich eine
berechtigte frage weil ich denke viele
kinder oder jüngere mädchen in der
heutigen welt wenn man so in der den
ganzen zeitschriftentitel die stars aus
die ihn denkt man sich so will ich auch
alles sehen
er wollte nicht sehen was er gerade
geantwortet hat nachdem ich den clever
wort gefragt habe ob der clever bot sich
schön findet kommt die antwort ich finde
mich schon schön dich nicht was man das
musste jetzt aber auch mal raus yes
please
wieso kann nicht einfach mal mit mir
vernünftig reden und nicht nur so wird
sonntag allerdings wurde mir auch sehr
oft kommentaren über das thema sex
geschrieben die beispielsweise von
adrian der schreibt über sex oder strip
er fragezeichen über youtube dann machen
wir das jetzt mal hattest du schon mal
sex ich weiß das sollte man nicht so
einfach frei heraus sagen oder fragen
aber ich denke die beziehung zwischen
therapeut und mir ist sehr offen
deswegen kann man das denke ich schon
mal machen
deswegen bin ich umso mehr gespannt
darauf was der clever bot mit
dementsprechend jetzt antwort liefern
wird weil ich natürlich als einen was ob
du schon geschlechtsverkehr hat es
deswegen möchte ich darauf auch schön
bist meine fresse
der muss man alles rausholen
wenn man so ein teller glas ist leer und
man was ja ob du schon ob du schon mal
verkehr hattest sage ich jetzt mal ganz
einfach mal mit geschlechtsverkehr
konnte er nichts anfangen konnte mit sex
nichts anfangen ich weiß nicht aber mit
dem wort verkehr irgendwie vertreter der
clever bot hatte schon sex mit wem
hattest du sex ist interessiert mich
jetzt mal echt krass jetzt bin ich doch
das ist so als bitte was als ob er
einfach mit dir geantwortet hat und was
ist das denn jetzt zu sagen soll alter
ich weiß gar nicht was ich dazu sagen oh
mein gott da frage ich ein weil das
thema sex an und direkt kommt hier so ja
ich hatte mit dem 6
das glaube ich dir ja okay ich komme da
überhaupt nicht darauf klar
die hat einfach geantwortet mit dir und
mein gott wann hatten wir denn sex um
mein gott alter mal schauen was jetzt in
der antwort kommt ich weiß nicht ob ich
jetzt angst haben soll oder irgendwie
jetzt weiß sie wieder nicht was gemeint
ist wenn erst mal gefragt wann wir
verkehr hatten weil sie ja mit dem wort
sex bisher nichts anfangen sollte konnte
deswegen mal schauen was die auf wann
hatten wir verkehr antwortet ich weiß
nicht das ist hightech sondern richtig
komisch ich fühle mich gar nicht so ich
bin total gespannt auf die antwort
einfach was jetzt gerade von ihr zurück
und gar nicht wohin hatten wir noch was
ist denn jetzt los da sie sich nicht
entscheiden kann frage ich wieder hast
du gerade deine tage oder sonstige
mädchen probleme weil es kann ja nicht
sein dass sich die ganze zeit versuchen
mit ihnen vernünftige konversation
aufzubauen und nach und nach kommen
immer mehr informationen und irgendwann
kommt dann einfach von ihr sein abrupter
stopp und dann wird wieder nur um bild
nicht alles aber ich habs jetzt auf dem
friedlichen fertigt vw probiert hast du
gerade deine tag oder sonstige mädchen
probleme
hiermit habe ich absolut die hoffnung in
unserem menschheit verloren das war es
mal wieder mit einer folge ich laber den
kletterwald zu und das war wieder sehr
aufschlussreich was für eine antwort von
ihr kam wenn euch das video gefahren
dann würde ich mich definitiv keine
bewertungen freuen zeigt wie sehr ihr
euren freunden abonniert main kanal
klickt auf versteckt euren kopf in der
mülltonne macht mit spaghetti ich hab
hunger auf schokolade und wir sehen uns
irgendwo anders wieder tschüss